Let's refactor that Saga code from earlier, and
run a new version in our simulated interpreter.
So here's a crazy idea.
What if we could somehow keep a reference to each of
the Saga functions that we create during the invocation of new Saga?
And we could keep them around forever, such that they were
available long after those new Saga calls had completed and returned.
So which of these techniques do you think we could use to retain access to
the Saga functions even after the new saga calls the created then had returned?
Would it work to pass saga to setTimeout or
return saga from the new saga function or save saga into some global variable?